a ruling that stopped Clark County from
enforcing an ordinance on short-term
rentals is being appealed now to the
Nevada Supreme Court now the ordinance
is seeking to cap the number of people
in short-term rentals to just 10 people
at a time it also requires rentals to be
a thousand feet away from each other
previously a district court judge called
that ordinance unconstitutional and as
County Commissioner tick seekerbloom
tells us the plans are going forward the
judge ruled and found some of the things
were inappropriate but actually upheld
the majority of the rule of the law so
the ordinance is going to go forward as
you know right now nothing is legal
until this ordinance is finally adopted
so tomorrow County Commissioners will
review all of the potential changes to
the ordinance that can then be approved
on April 4th the lottery that selects
prospective short-term rental host is
scheduled for next Wednesday the 29th